[Music]
welcome back America Kaylee mckinin is
one of the smartest people on TV maybe
period also one of the nicest she's a
co-host of outnumbered former White
House Press Secretary to president Trump
she wrote the book Serenity in the storm
which was a great book Kaylee mckin
immigration and the economy are the two
big issues and they should be and this
is where Biden is a complete another
failure I want to talk about immigration
with you you see that largely black
communities in Chicago and New York and
elsewhere are fed up with illegal
immigration it's affecting the lives of
people it's affecting them in their
homes it's affecting them in their in
their schools it's affecting them in
their parks and so forth and so
on and yet the Democrats keep doing this
and the City Mayors don't blame Biden
and the Democrats they blame Republicans
and comprehensive immigration reform
what do you make of this yeah it's
really interesting uh when you look at
the political landscape of this issue
first the reason Biden's doing this
everyone says why wouldn't he just
secure the Border come on it would
behoove him look at the polling 41% of
Iowa caucus goers said immigration is
the most important issue well he can't
because of the progressives jaia Paul
came out this week and said look not
going to let you do this President Obama
or excuse me President Biden um because
voters across the country progressives
across the country won't show up for you
I'm paraphrasing but that's in essence
what she said so he's beholding to this
Progressive base meanwhile the American
people suffer you point it out New York
Chicago these are blue jurisdictions
where there's a groundwell of people
saying our jobs are being taken our
safety is being compromised you have
illegal immigrants who can now go
through airports without having their
picture taken uh there was the reporting
last year that they can show uh warrants
warrants uh arrest warrants as proof of
identification this is total and
complete Insanity it reminds me if 2016
when President Trump was first on the
horizon made this an issue and then went
on to to win the presidency what do you
make of the fact that you have these
radical Marxist Democrats in Congress
one of them holds up these Statute of
Liberty and says I guess the Republicans
are opposed to this we should take it
down because that stands for immigration
and so what this isn't immigration
immigration is a rational process where
people come in they're vetted uh to make
sure they're not criminals they're not
terrorists they don't have some
communicable disease and so forth and so
on that's immigration this is a cled imp
Piven this is destroy the system
overwhelm the system this is intentional
we don't know who's coming in Who's got
what where they're going I don't know
where 8 10 12 million people are in this
country we see them here and there but
we don't see them generally isn't this
really an attempt
ultimately to destroy the country
internally that's exactly what it is I
mean how can you say it's anything but
that I mean to your point there's a
difference between legal immigration and
illegal immigration I remember back when
I was on the presidential campaign
meeting a voter who was literally so
emotional because one of her relatives
had just gotten citizenship into the
country it was a yearslong process and
the scourge of illegal immigration to
compare that um they're really two
entirely different things but what's
interesting is what Democrats will try
to do with this I remember earlier in
the week Quenton folks he's the deputy
campaign manager joined Brett Bear and
tried to say the Border was Secure the
problem was worse under President Trump
what a joke what a laughable thing and
they're rolling out this talking point
Quinton folks did it then kamla Harris
did it on The View this week we tried it
was a day one priority we put forward
legislation it was Republicans who
wouldn't work with us what a joke what a
lie Republicans passed hr2 which took us
back to Trump era border policies but
make no mistake they will try to deceive
on this issue though I think it will be
very difficult when you look on what's
happening in blue jurisdictions it's
gotten to Blue jurisdictions it's
amazing to your point so they have this
talking point they always have talking
points cuz they're Liars CU their
policies fail cuz their ideology is
corrupt and it's anti-American as you
can see on the border it's amazing they
never take credit for the destruction
that they create it's uh Israel's fault
it's Putin's fault it's the oil
company's fault it's the pharmaceutical
company's fault uh On the Border it's
the Republican and Trump's fault well
let me say this about their point you
don't need any legislation do you all
you have to do is reverse what you've
done and put all of Trump's policy back
in place and follow the damn law
wouldn't that fix it yes uh the RNC
actually fact checked them Mark so in
the first 100 days Biden took 94
executive actions to roll back the Trump
era policies and they say oh there's
nothing we can do okay remain in Mexico
okay title 42 okay when Trump threatened
tariffs on our Southern border on Mexico
what happened troops were sent to our
Southern border to Mexico's northern
border from Mex meico there is an ample
amount you could do so don't act as if
you are this helpless person who this
problem is happening to but Mark here's
where Republicans are so advantaged the
economy is an issue that you feel you
feel it always I remember a CNN
commentator saying to me days before the
2016 election look wages are going up if
only the people knew well the economy is
something people could feel either it's
going up or it's not and people know
immigration was largely an issue cabin
to Texas to California that has changed
with the brilliance of Greg Abbott and
other Republican Governor saying look
we're sharing this problem you cannot
hide this issue it is now surged to the
top of issues alongside the economy and
Democrats I think they're scrambling
with what to do about it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else